[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Mark
starts off this hour in Springfield
Missouri hey Mark welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave um I got a question I know
how the baby steps work but I'm i' I've
got a little bit of a quandry as to
where I need to put my wife's student
loans in this because she is still in
school and not having to pay on them so
do I put them in because she's got 12
loans do I put them in where they go and
slow my snowball down or do I put them
at the end and continue my snowball
until I get to them I'd put them in
where they go she's got 12 of them so
I'd list i' I'd put those in smallest to
larg just along with your other debts
and you might have one student loan and
then a credit card and then a student
loan and then a car payment and then you
know it doesn't all have to be by group
and I think sometimes in our minds we
want it to be that way but that's okay
just put them in as they go smallest to
largest how much student loan debt is
there it's 58,000 and how much other
debt is there uh there's two cars um one
is 9,000 and one is
13,000 and the student loans only one of
them is more than the first car so I'm
going to be paying we're going to be
doing like 11 student loans and then a
car yeah it's
46,000 that I'm not gonna be building
what's your household in yeah you won't
be building any snowballing because you
don't have any payments on those to
cancel out I got you yes that's a good
point um so the uh what's your income
the household income is 170,000 and when
does she
graduate uh she'll graduate um she she's
doing part-time schooling so she's got
uh I think six semesters left and we can
have both of the cars paid off before
that are they are they subsidized or are
they
unsubsidized she's got two that are
getting taxes not taxes uh interest and
the rest of them aren't um say uh 58 and
right you said 58,000 student loan debt
and how much other yeah and then uh
9,000 on one car and 13 on another oh
okay so 31 and
58 right so 8080 89,000 it's l than that
no we're at 880,000 we're right at
880,000 yeah okay all right 79,000 I
added it wrong okay um and you make
170,000 yes okay explain to me why you
can't pay all this in a
year because we have eight
kids wow they don't eat that much you
can raise eight kids on 100 grand
well we the the eight kids are all
teenagers you can raise eight kids on
100 Grand man there's Sports there's
food there's all that stuff it's just
it's a year of
sacrifice yeah um because
170 minus 79 is one year you're debt
free I mean if you can't do a year
you''ll be able do it in 14 months uh I
think you're looking you know when you
said she's going to be six semesters and
you're just going to barely have two
cars paid off you're not making any
progress at all no we we'll have we'll
have the two cars paid off by August of
next year yeah you ought to have you
ought to be done by August of next year
the whole stinking thing are close so
are you paying cash for her College as
she goes yes we we have stopped with the
student loans we are paying cash for
everything now good and what is she
studying uh she's getting her master's
in uh
business like it's not the NBA but it's
it's a a business okay and and her
intention is to do what with her career
with eight kids uh to help me wearing my
business I see okay while you have eight
kids yes that are teenagers okay yes all
right and good well you're doing well
with your business sir is the 170,000
taxable net profit on your business or
is that your gross
revenues the the hund aund of it is from
my business that's the uh the taxes and
everything no that's before taxes and
everything before before before
expenses yes what do you take home from
the business as
payment um well I've been taking home uh
just
$800 a a week now what are you paying
taxes on on the $100,000 of Revenue that
this business creates you do not have a
household income of $170 that's why you
couldn't see doing this cuz you don't
have a net profit of 100,000 on the
business that's your gross revenues okay
yeah I'm not sure what it will be this
year because I I didn't make this much
last year so what you make last year
last year last year I only made 50,000
gross gross yeah did you net anything on
that uh not much we we still with the
money that she paid in for her taxes we
still got a tax return
so and we have we have fixed that I know
that you don't like to hear tax so we
have fixed that I'm still trying to
figure out if your business is making a
profit do you know what a profit is yes
I know what a profit is it's your
taxable income on the
business yes on $50,000 did you have to
pay any
taxes no because and you lost money on
$50,000 worth of Revenue with with what
my wife paid in on on her check here's
your wife your wife check's got nothing
to do with your business's profitability
you need to hire someone to run your
books yeah you need you going and learn
how to do a set of books that's the you
you you don't even have any idea if
you're making a
profit cuz a profit is your gross
revenues minus the expenses associated
with the business equals profit and I'm
not sure you made a profit on 50 Grand
so I'm not sure you're making a profit
on 100 Grand thus I think you're trying
to raise kids on 70
grand actual Revenue which is your your
actual other income not business related
income and yeah you're not going to pay
it off in a year doing that so we need
to figure out whether this calculation
right to tell you if my advice was bogus
but I have bad information from you mhm
even still they're still going to have
to walk through a debt snowball and if
the business is not making money they're
going to have to find more money coming
in yeah in order to make this happen
fast with eight kids you need to quit
running getting a master's degree to run
a business that isn't profit not making
money yeah that's that's losing money at
that point yeah it's already losing
money probably I can't tell can't tell
cuz he doesn't know but anyway yeah get
to the bottom let's figure out if you're
making a profit or not and if you're
expanding that cuz you definitely
increase your revenues but I'm not sure
you increased your profits because if
you lose 25 cents of watermelon you
don't just get a bigger truck that's not
how this works so
um all right uh then based on all of
that what would I do yeah I might pay
off the car first and let the student
loans set to the side for a minute at
least get rid of one of the dad gun
payments out of your tight budget but I
I can't tell what your budget is so it's
really hard to tell you if it's worth
doing that if you truly made a profit of
100,000 which I think we've established
you didn't um then you had $170,000
actual household income then I would go
back to my original thing and say shut
up and pay off the loans in a year or 14
months if 79,000 should go away but I
don't think that's the numbers so I
think it changed in the middle of the
conversation they did